ich möchte die politiker heute davon
überzeugen dass sie keine angst vor
china haben müssen und wenn sie mir
nicht glauben dann bestimmt dem
freundlichen huawei manager minister
chen china ist keine demokratie sondern
china hat eine politische diktatur
darüber wollen möchte er nicht reden
also die wir das ganze politische nicht
vorüber dass sie zustimmen und sagen
dass china das ist eine tolle sache ist
und sie gerne mit ihr zusammenarbeiten
ich würde also jetzt frei muss sich
bewerben wie andere auch und das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik muss zu dem ergebnis
kommen dass eine manipulierbarkeit
ausgeschlossen ist java minister gesagt
wenn sie nicht für way stimmen wird er
persönlich dafür sorgen dass ihnen das
internet abgestellt wird
er soll einmal versuchen
[Musik]
die chinesen sind doch wenigstens
höflich der amerikaner stinker zurzeit
nur um den chinesen höflich er ist auch
offen
er hört ab ja ok aber er macht
wenigstens offen haben möglicherweise
alle und deshalb sage ich ja gar nicht
auf einen verlassen sondern wir setzen
einfach auf alle sich von allen abhören
lassen
neben von keinem amerika oder china es
ist wie bushido man muss sich für einen
klaren entscheiden und dann doch am
besten für den gefährlicheren oder naja
also am besten wäre es wir hätten
europäischen champion und da müssen wir
ein bisschen länger warten bis wir das
hinkriegen könnten sie mir vielleicht
noch mal gerade ihr handy geben bis
dahin würde nummer kurz schauen ob das
auf dem neuesten stand uns lieber nicht
nur kurz er will einfach nicht kurzen
sicherheitscheck ja wir können ihm
vertrauen
da möchte er so nicht darüber reden dass
das eine diktatur ist dass er möchte
dass sie das zurücknehmen
das kann ich mir vorstellen nämlich die
haben ja auch dafür gesorgt dass von dem
schrecklichen massaker am platz
überhaupt nichts mehr in der
öffentlichkeit bekannt dass er möchte
dass sie sofort schweigen sonst kriegen
sie richtig probleme alte huawei bietet
uns die beste technik zum besten preis
und wir haben doch nichts zu verbergen
oder haben sie nichts zu verbergen und
ich habe nichts zu verbergen soll sie
doch mit höheren sie haben nichts zu
verbergen
da haben sie ein unglaublich
langweiliges privatleben
das tief verbeugen wayne große nummer
das ist auch in ihrem interesse dass sie
da ein bisschen kontakte knüpfen
tiefer kann ich auch sind verbeugen das
gehört sich so
[Gelächter]
mister schenk macht ein angebot sie
stimmen huawei zu und im gegenzug bricht
der mir dafür nicht den kleinen finger
was interessiert mich denn ihr kleiner
für die sind so ein bisschen kritisch
was vorangeht minister chen würde gern
foto von ihnen macht es bräuchte er für
seine unterlagen ein problem
ich sagte ihm wie es ist sie haben
probleme ja interessant es gab durchaus
auch kritische stimmen hier war es war
ja ein abhörgerät minister chen nimmt
den beitrag so nicht ab ich mach es
nochmal und damit zurück ins studio
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünscht
überall liegen und ihr lastet das xenix
ein beschissenes ab
[Musik]